[MUSIC PLAYING]
SACHIT EGAN: I'm
really excited today
to introduce a new friend
of mine, Carine McCandless.
She's the sister of literary
icon Christopher McCandless
and she consulted
closely with Jon Krakauer
on his bestselling
book, "Into the Wild,"
which came out in 1996.
I'm sure a lot of you have
heard of it or read it.
She also worked as a direct
adviser, writer, and script
contributor to Sean Penn
on his film adaptation
of "Into the Wild," which
was released in 2007.
Carine wrote her own
memoir about the experience
called "The Wild Truth."
That was released
in November 2014
and very quickly became
both a New York Times
and national bestseller.
And it was followed by
international publications
in seven countries
and still counting.
"The Wild Truth" was
selected for many best books
of 2014 lists, including those
chosen by readers and editors
at "Newsweek," "Vanity
Fair," Amazon, and Indy Next.
So it's a pleasure
to introduce Carine.
[APPLAUSE]
CARINE MCCANDLESS: I thank you
all for hosting me here today.
I'll keep things pretty casual.
I've got my journal.
Everyone should always write
in a journal every day.
I had to put markers in
mine of the Google color
and your logo to remind
me where in the journal
I needed to go back to.
So anyway, I'm used to
doing very, very long
and formal presentations
so I've got my journal here
to help me stay on point
because I really would like
to get some time at the
end of this to get into Q&A
with you guys.
So when I was 21, I
lost my best friend.
He was also my brother.
He was 24 when he died.
And many of you know the story.
His name was Chris McCandless.
He had graduated with
honors from Emory University
and that was the last time
that I had ever seen him alive,
it was the last time I'd spoken.
He had written me letters,
but I hadn't spoken to him
since seeing him at graduation.
Two years later,
his body was found
in this abandoned
bus in the middle
of the Alaskan wilderness.
There was a lot of
mystery surrounding
his death and everything that
had happened during those two
years.
And the story of that time
and all of the adventures
that he had during
that time became
known as "Into
the Wild," as such
summarized the incredible
book written by Jon Krakauer.
And then it was also developed
into a film by Sean Penn.
And Chris' story really became--
I mean, John's book
was so popular it's
published in over 30 languages.
Sean's movie, also so
beautiful, and Chris' story
reached even more of
a global audience.
But it wasn't the whole story.
So to give you a
little back story,
this is Chris with the
Shenandoah behind him.
We used to hike a lot--
this is my hiking hat--
in that area.
And he loves to
be out in nature.
Chris always said
to me that nature
may be harsh in its honesty,
but it never lies to you.
And he felt--
I don't know, he felt
whole, he felt real
when he was out in nature.
And I just remember it was
always his favorite place
to be.
It was always an escape for
him, even at this young age.
Chris and I were very close.
He was always my protector.
It's a cute picture, right?
All right.
This picture tells a story.
This picture was taken
on a typical morning.
Our house was on an
everyday basis filled
with domestic violence and this
day was not unlike any other.
The violence had erupted
over the breakfast table
and continued on until
my parents realized
that it was time for church.
It was Easter Sunday so
we were put into our best
suit and dress and
we were marched
into the backyard for pictures.
And pictures, they catch
an image in time, right,
but you don't really
know what's going on.
You don't know the whole
story behind the image.
And whenever we
would have to pause
for the perfect little
family pictures,
our dad would behind the
camera screaming at us smile.
Smile.
So what we had just been
through in the household,
really not in the mood
but you had to do it.
And if you didn't, I knew
what was coming next.
Now, look closely at our
expressions in these pictures.
So I'm being compliant,
I've got a smile on my face.
I've got my hand
behind his back,
I'm trying to convince Chris
smile, let's get this done.
And look at the look on his
face if you really look closely.
He's only about
six years old here,
but he's already
older than that.
He already understands.
Now, what's really important
about this picture--
I've got it on the
cover of my book
because people look at
that and they're like, oh,
that's such a sweet picture.
But again, it's the point of
the story behind the images
that we see, right?
That's what this whole
talk is going to be about.
And I can remember it
like it was yesterday.
You have this image that
you're going to portray out
to society, but sometimes
it's so very different
from what is actually going on.
So Chris just, even at that age
he wasn't going to accept that.
He was already planning.
He was already at
that young age making
a determination of what's
right and what's wrong.
When you grow up in a
household of domestic violence,
you become acclimated to it.
You don't know at this
age that every household
isn't like that.
You don't understand.
So when your environment
is saturated with that,
you become completely
desensitized to it.
Chris understood
something was wrong.
Now, as we grew up,
in a lot of ways
Chris was your typical
kid, but in other ways
there was just
something about him
that I don't know you could
say was deeper than most people
at that age.
And sometimes we would
just be having typical kid
conversations or we would be
fighting over that's my space
or don't come in my room,
but other times we'd
be having these conversations
about an author or something
that he just read that he wanted
me to read or big questions
and I was more interested
in the stuffed animals
at that age or makeup
at a later age.
Chris was different.
At this age, he was
already thinking
a lot about who he
wanted to be and probably
most importantly, who
he would not become.
So John's book became
required reading.
"Into the Wild" became
required reading
at about 3,000 high
schools and colleges
across the United States.
John doesn't like to
do public speaking
so he would suggest me.
And it took me a very,
very, very long time
to get to the point where I felt
comfortable going and speaking
to people about Chris' story.
And when I did, I would
be talking to students
who are about this age.
This is Chris' typical senior
picture in high school, right?
And when I came
to the school, you
would see a change
in these students
because it became real to them.
It was no longer
just an assignment,
it was this lesson because
this is a real flesh and blood
sister of this person.
And it wasn't just that
I could see that they
were inspired by Chris.
There's usually two
camps, some people
admired him for what he did,
some people admonished him.
That's part of the
reason that it's
something that's assigned,
right, because they want people
to get into that
critical kind of thinking
and think outside of themselves.
But what hit me more was that
I never left one school--
first of all, they always
asked about the back story,
right, which at first I wasn't
necessarily talking about.
But in the Q&A, that's always
what the questions were--
why was he so angry
with your parents,
why did he leave the way
he did, why didn't he
talk to anybody for those
years after he left college?
And when I opened up in the
safety of the intimate walls
of a classroom where things
weren't recorded yet,
I saw this change come
over the students,
and some in particular.
Because I never left one
school, and still to this day
all the years that
I've been speaking,
I've never left one school, one
university a corporate event,
I've never left anywhere where
at least one person didn't
come up.
And in this case, it was
these high school students
that didn't come up and ask for
help for the very first time
because they were going
through a similar experience
and here was someone
talking about it.
So after years of doing this and
seeing this everywhere I went,
I realized what a disservice
I had done to my brother--
and not just to Chris, but
those who would read about him
and be inspired by him.
Because Chris always
said there is nothing
more important than the truth.
And John did an job
writing "Into the Wild."
and what was left
out of it is my fault
because I wanted
John to understand,
but I wouldn't let
him write that.
I wasn't ready.
And I realized
later on, wow, what
a disservice I had done to
such an incredible writer
and someone with that
journalistic style, Jon
Krakauer, to give
them information
but tell him beforehand, I'm
going to tell you something
but my condition is you're
not allowed to reveal this.
I just need you to know.
I didn't think anybody was
going to read "Into the Wild,"
so it's kind of Jon's
fault. So anyway, I
realized what a disservice I had
done by not talking about this.
And here 20 years has passed.
So as I mentioned earlier,
I journal all the time.
Chris was the one that
taught me to journal
and we'll get a little
bit more into that.
But I just started writing.
And all of those journal
entries turned into a book.
And what I didn't
expect was for my book
to start a new conversation
about domestic violence.
There were all these
blanks in Chris' story
and people, rightfully
so, had filled
in those blanks with
their own answers
as to why he had
left the way he did
or what had happened
with the family.
And when my book came out, or
long before the book came out--
just when I was in these rooms
of 50 people, 500 people,
it didn't matter--
when I would talk about
the rest of the story,
it forced people to take
another look at Chris' story.
Not in defense of him,
because in all fairness,
he didn't live his life worried
about what anyone else was
going to think about him.
He was concerned about what
he thought about himself.
But now that people had
the rest of the answers,
a lot of their
perspectives changed
and that was not
something that I realized
when I was 21 years
old and he was gone
and I was having to tell
this journalist why he left.
So people not only would take
another look at Chris' story,
but they started taking
another look at story
in their own communities.
And I started doing
the same thing.
So whenever I was
at these schools--
and for the most
part, these are--
if they're hiring
a speaker to come.
these schools are
filled with kids
who have a certain amount
of privilege, right?
They're all wearing pretty
nice clothes, when I pull up
to speak there's tons of
cars in the parking lot
so pretty much all these
kids have access to cars,
they drive for school; they all
have phones, right, computers
and tablets.
So they all want to connect
with me on social media
and I've never really been
big on having a social media
presence.
My publisher is so incredibly
kind and patient with me
for you're really supposed
to be on a lot and I'm not.
But I do try and make an effort.
And for the most
part, it's when I'm
connecting with these
students because I want
to stay connected with them.
I want to see what
they're doing.
I want to see what they're
doing with their lives.
I want to hear what
they're doing next.
Because they'll tell
me their stories.
They'll tell me how they
were inspired by Chris
and what they want to do.
But as I am looking at the
social media of these kids
that I've connected with--
and these are good kids--
I'm also seeing all these other
stories, right, also good kids
but all these other pages and
connections that populate,
right?
So I don't have to tell you--
I'm at Google-- but you're
looking at social media
and then someone
else has commented
and then that's curious so
I'm going to click on that,
I'm going to look at that.
And I think that kid might
have been at the lecture,
let me look at that.
So I started to connect more
and more into the social media
and with this age group.
And in paying more
attention to what
I saw through them, their
friends, their classmates,
I really began to see
something that concerned me.
There was a lot of good, but
there was also a lot of bad.
And to me, it appeared
that what I considered
to be a negative influence
and negative stimuli,
it was quite out of whack
i you look at the balance.
And what I could see was there's
so much stimuli and reality
becomes a blur.
There's just so much going on.
And that's what I
want to get into.
Some of the things that I
started to see-- so I just
grabbed some screen shots.
I would look at
pages of students
that I connected with
across the country,
but I also took a closer
look in my own community.
So I started looking at easy--
search the name of your
kid or your kids' friends
or all these kids go to the
high schools around the area.
And these are some of
the things that I saw.
So here is one that's
got a few pictures
and it says, grab your
girl like this, right?
It's got I don't know what emoji
that is, a funny crying face
and then it's got
the hearts, right,
smiley face with the hearts.
It's got to have a name, I don't
know what that emoji is called.
But now let's take a closer
look at these four photos
that they have.
So no big deal, right-- don't
be an overprotective mom,
that's not a big deal, right?
It's just a little--
nothing graphic.
So there's three of these shots.
I guess it's cool that they
have cigarettes, whatever.
All right.
And then this is the fourth one.
When I saw that, I
found that shocking.
Grab your girl like this.
What I found more shocking was--
and let's go back,
maybe it's on here.
OK.
Let's see.
There's 14-- now I'm watching
these things in real time.
So this goes up and
then I'm watching it
over a matter of that day.
There's 1,400-- kind
of sucks getting old.
I need my reading glasses--
1,400 retweets and,
what, 1,372 likes.
What is there to
like about this?
like about that?
All right.
So then I started
looking at more things.
And I saw this theme
and this pattern that
caused me a lot of concern.
So here's just another one.
OK.
So this is a meme, right?
They call it a meme.
So here's a skeleton getting
ready to punch a baby.
And it says, this is how infants
are killed during an abortion.
Now, I'm not here to talk
about abortion rights
or anything like that.
That's a whole
other topic, right?
But I think it's fair to say
that both sides of that issue
could agree that this
is inappropriate.
This is a skeleton
cold cocking a baby.
And again, you've
got 2,300 retweets,
almost 3,500 favorites.
Now, majority of
what I'm seeing,
these are school aged kids,
right, these are teenagers.
This meme mentality
to me, they're
so separated from reality.
it's like everything's
a cartoon, not real.
But that's a real issue, right?
And they don't know the
intent of the person that drew
this meme or posted it, right?
Are they saying that this is--
do they think abortion
is fair, it's all right,
are they're against it?
They don't know.
I started to interview
these kids, right?
I started talking to
the kids in groups.
And I'd show these things
and I would say, why?
Why would you show this?
And they literally
would like-- they
know it's supposed
to be bad, they
have to cover their face like
they just thought it was funny.
What about that is funny?
And I would say, OK, and I
would name the person that I
had blocked out that said this.
Do you know who that person is?
No.
So you don't know what
their intent is behind this.
Is this a real picture?
I don't know.
How would you like it
if that was your sister?
They're horrified.
That's someone's sister.
You don't know
what the intent is
of the person that posted
this, yet you are readily
reposting it.
And that's what I mean by
this just constant stimuli.
They see something, oh
ha-ha and it's peers,
everybody's retweeting,
everybody's liking
so they do it too.
They don't even know
why they're doing it.
They don't think
about the effect,
they don't think
about the intent.
The messages that society
spreads are so important.
And through social media, we
are willingly and incessantly
spreading messages
without knowing what
the intent of that message is.
So it's like that
noise of society.
And when you talk about purpose
in everything that you do,
that intent is so important.
So when you aren't
listening to yourself
and you lose that
self-awareness,
you lose that accountability
for what you're
doing with your own actions.
So up to this, it leads me
to contradiction, right?
A lot of times
you're not thinking
about what you're
doing, a lot of times
you do contradictory things.
This is a 17-year-old
girl that posted this.
Right?
Am I just an overprotective
mother, right,
am I just like
someone who thinks,
oh my god, if that
was my daughter.
It's not graphic, right?
I mean, there's
ads for underwear
that aren't that
different than that.
But look what it
says, if we date
with the emoji with the tongue.
But look at-- this is
her favorites-- look
at the post right before it.
The new Steven Universe episode
was about sexual harassment.
This show was so important.
So she's telling people
this is so important
and let's see, there's
five likes of that.
Yet the very next thing she
favorites is this photograph.
And she writes, if we date.
And there's 349
retweets and 562 likes.
It's completely contradictory.
And I have to say that
it's not that untypical.
Here's another one.
If she sucks your
fingers, keep her.
She nasty.
I mean-- and oh,
yeah, there's a hell
of a lot to retweets
and likes of that one.
So these are just your
typical teenage kids.
These are not these
troublemaking kids
and oh, my kid
would never do that.
I know who these kids
are, they're good kids.
But it's they become
desensitized to this, right?
And it leads to more and
more and more problems.
And while I'm
picking on the kids,
I've got to say adults too
oftentimes are no better.
So we will have
an NFL player that
gets filmed in an elevator
hitting a woman, right?
We will have a politician
that gets caught
for sexual harassment, we will
have news anchors, celebrities,
same thing happens.
And sometimes they get away with
it, sometimes the hammer falls,
they lose their jobs, right?
And so women, we as women
stand up and we say,
we are not going to
accept this behavior.
This is wrong.
It is wrong for women to not
be treated fairly, right?
We want to demand
fair treatment,
we want an end to
sexual harassment,
we want an end to an abuse
of power and control.
Did you "Fifty
Shades of Gray" yet?
Let's read it for our
book club and then
we'll all go see
the movie together.
It's a total contradiction.
It's a complete contradiction.
This is the message that
we're sending to our daughters
and to the boys
that they will date.
So this leads me to did
anybody read this book yet,
Jon Krakauer, "Missoula?"
Heard of it before?
OK.
How many of you have heard
of "Fifty Shades of Gray?"
OK.
So if you have a child
going to college,
you have got to make
them read this book.
This should be the FYE book
for every student going
into college.
Jon does not need my
help to sell any books
and I'm not doing that for this.
This because I believe in this.
My 18-year-old will
not go to college
without reading this
book, college or not,
wherever they go.
So "Missoula," John in
his journalistic style
investigates the
campus rape culture.
And I am not asked to
go speak to any colleges
anymore without addressing
the issue of sexual violence.
Every college I go to, they want
me to merge that into my talk.
It is a huge issue.
But look at some of the things
we just saw on social media
and it goes back
to self-awareness
and accountability.
In Jon's book, the overwhelming
majority of these cases
are you have a young
man and a young woman
and in the
overwhelming majority,
they were highly intoxicated
when this event happened.
So there's interviews
and intercourse happened
and somebody thought
that it was consensual
and the other
person didn't think
it is but they know
that they blacked out
and the other person
blacked out, too.
And so piecing that all
together is difficult.
And it goes back to what
I try to talk to students
about is self-awareness.
It's not just what's
my purpose in life
and what am I going
to do with my career?
It's being aware of your space
and your time right now where
you are, what you're
doing, and if you
have control of your
intent and do others around
you have control of theirs?
To me, so much goes back to--
and this is like this.
There's this controversy
of truth, right?
What's the truth?
And there will be
controversy about that,
but is it getting
enough attention
for the right reasons?
It brings me back
to the influences
surrounding these students that
are on their way to college.
Let me give you a
little bit of levity.
As I was on my book tour not
long after Jon's book had come
out, I go into a bookstore.
And I'm always looking to
see what books are out there.
And I'm looking at
Jon's books and Jon
has several bestsellers.
And you usually
see a few copies.
And then I also happened to
see Charles Krauthammer's book
and I like him.
And I picked it up and I'm
on a long layover in Chicago
so I'm reading the
chapter that he entitles,
"In Defense of the F Word"--
which is brilliant, by the way.
So I'm looking at that.
But as I'm reading, I'm
standing there reading
and I'm distracted.
I'm like there's
something that's
catching my eye peripherally.
And it was boobs.
It was a big set of boobs.
Everyone knows who
that is, right?
So there's like three copies
of Jon's book, "Missoula,"
there's a few copies of
Charles Krauthammer's.
There's like 50
copies of this book
and this is Kim
Kardashian's book entitled--
it's her book of selfies.
And no, I'm not trying to
harp on Kim or anything.
I'm just saying, let's
use this as an example
because she certainly doesn't
mind putting it out there.
There's like 50 copies of
this book on the shelf.
The book's entitled "Selfish."
And why does the bookstore
have so many of her copies?
It's a big book, too.
I mean, you're in an airport
bookstore, it's heavy.
Why are there so many
copies on that shelf?
Because they know they're
going to sell them.
It's society.
And while I was looking
up to find this cover,
I found this one, which
I thought was hilarious--
Kim Carr-Dachshund, "Shellfish."
I thought that was brilliant.
All right.
Let me bring things back.
OK.
So this just brings me
back to the influence
surrounding teenagers, right?
And not just kids of
this age, but little kids
because the little brothers
and sisters of kids these age
want to be just like them.
They can't wait to get their
iPhones, their androids.
They can't wait to get
their phones, right?
And that's what they
see all the time.
They are very aware of what
the teenagers are doing.
Does anyone know-- this
is someone in particular.
Does anyone know who this is?
Does anybody recognize?
OK.
And I take this around to--
I've taken this around
to a lot of students
in different schools
all over the country.
Almost nobody knows
who this person is.
Lately, though, everybody
knows who this person is.
Right?
I know some of you are--
which is-- but now what if
I said, catch me outside,
how about that?
Right?
You know who that is because
it's all over the internet.
So I didn't know who it
was, but on Saturday I
had my littlest girl,
my youngest daughter,
at ukulele lessons.
And he said, you're speaking at
Google on Tuesday, aren't you?
And I said, yeah.
And I told them what
the title of my talk
was going to be, "The
Socialization of Domestic
Violence: Diluting a
Devastating Influence."
And he says, oh, yeah.
He teaches at the
Academy of Rock
and so he's got a
group of students.
He goes in one day and
they're all joking and saying,
catch me outside,
how about that?
And he says, are you
speaking English?
What are you saying?
So then they tell him.
They pull out their
phones and they show him.
Look at this girl,
it's hilarious.
And he's thinking, oh my gosh.
Well, so he starts telling
me about this person
and come to find out
she on "Dr. Phil."
And I watched the video on
YouTube and during the video,
she threatens to
beat the audience up.
That's what the
catch me outside,
how about that is-- she's
going to beat the audience up.
Her mother translated.
And and then she got up and
she got up in her mother's face
and she was threatening
to beat up her mom.
This girl apparently now
has endorsement deals,
she's signed a contract
for a reality show.
Let's see how many
views are on this?
5.5 million views, right?
This is the other picture.
This is Jack Andraka, I hope
I'm saying the last name right.
I met him-- he probably
won't remember me,
but I definitely remembered him.
I met him at an NYU conference.
Both of our books
were featured as books
to use as required
reading at colleges.
And he presented.
And this is a young
teenage genius--
he's now at Stanford,
class of 2019--
who invented an early--
he invented a--
I don't even have the to
explain it all properly.
But he developed a
very economical test
sets an early detector
for pancreatic cancer
because he lost
someone in his life
to pancreatic cancer that
was very dear to him.
He's also invented a
water bottle that--
not these expensive ones that
we buy at the sports stores,
but something that can be
manufactured for pennies
on the dollar compared
to others and can
be sent to these
third world countries
where people don't have
access to clean water.
And they can go and scoop up
this water that's not drinkable
and they drink.
So he's saving lives,
he's changing the world.
None of the teenagers
know who this is.
Here's jack Ted talk.
It's got 304,000 views.
That's pretty good.
She's got 5.5 million views.
It doesn't mean that
they are approving of it,
but that's saturation.
That's influential.
Because whereas some of these
kids might kind of laugh at her
and talk about how much,
they also are thinking,
wow, she's made all that money.
I mean, they're human.
That's the kind of things
that they think about.
Kids think about
shoes and they want
the Range Rover like
somebody else has.
So let's see, here's
her, Danielle Bregoli,
I guess is her name.
Here's her Twitter page.
She's got 243,000
followers and she just
joined February of 2017.
So in just a couple of months,
she's got that many followers.
Here's Jack's page.
He joined in July of 2011.
He's got just under
22,000 followers.
Here's his Instagram page.
He's got 3,400 followers.
He's probably had it
up for several years.
Here's her Instagram
page, 9.2 million.
9.2 million
followers, which means
when these kids go and scroll
the latest video that she
posted bragging about
bullying people and beating up
kids and stealing cars,
there's only 3,400
that are learning about
Jack's latest invention that's
going to change this world.
But what did we as a society--
why?
Why does everybody
not know who this is?
Why do they know who she is?
You don't have to be
intentionally searching
for something negative,
but it's so saturated
that that's what's out there.
Now, I'm not saying that
there isn't also good
that comes with the
exposure, right?
I mean, technology has
been a wonderful thing.
So here's an organization,
nomore.org, right?
They've been fantastic.
I've spoken all around
the country at groups
and a lot of times they
are related in some way
to this group in support.
I've spoken at New Beginnings
in Seattle, Center for Women
in Transition in Michigan,
the Women's Home in Texas,
Samaritan House where I
live in Virginia, Shelter
House, The Barn outside of DC.
There's organizations
all over the country
that are working to prevent
domestic and sexual violence.
And they're out there.
But this group has
55,000 followers.
55,000 followers
compared to nine--
well, let's be fair.
That was her Instagram page.
Instagram, they have almost
30,000 followers compared
to what was hers, 9.2 million?
There's something
wrong with that.
And I don't have
all the answers,
but I know there's
something wrong with that.
This is the kind of
thing that concerns me
because it's out of balance.
I care about it because I'm
worried for these kids who
see domestic violence
every day and they
have become acclimated to it
and don't understand it's wrong.
I worry for these kids.
These are my girls,
Heather and Christiana.
I love that picture.
They're bigger now so they don't
like when I show that picture.
Heather thinks that she doesn't
look good without makeup
and that her hair is too curly.
So here's another
picture of Heather.
So I worry about
this as a mom, I
worry about this
as an advocate, I
worry about this as
a community member.
But I also worry
about this as a sister
because I am desperate to
know that as a human race
that we have learned something
in the past 25 years.
It's been 25 years.
But I don't have the power and
I don't have all the answers,
right?
I'm one person.
There are a lot of advocates
all over the country.
Who does have the power?
I think you guys have the power.
We're at freaking Google, right?
What's a Google?
Google is like the highest
number you can get, right?
10 to 100th power.
I'm not a mathematician,
I Google it.
These pages that populate, these
recommendations that come up,
somebody is programming
all that stuff.
Somebody is creating that.
Some of the most brilliant
minds are in this 100 plus
set of buildings.
Why can't we come
up with a way that
helps with a better balance?
I'm not talking
about censorship,
I'm talking about balance.
I'm talking about educating
these young people.
There's got to be
a way to do it.
And I challenge you guys to
come up with those answers.
So I think that can
bring us into the Q&A.
You guys have everyone's
attention every day.
You and companies like yours
have everyone's attention
every day, so what can you
do to help with this balance?
[APPLAUSE]
SACHIT EGAN: So what I take
away from hearing you talk
and reading your book
is that in his own way,
Chris in his time when he was
coming of age was frustrated
by a lot of the things
you just mentioned--
maybe not Instagram and
Twitter back then, but--
CARINE MCCANDLESS: Right.
It didn't exist back then.
That's one of my points.
Students will say to
me, weren't you just
pissed that he didn't
send you a text?
You didn't hear from
him for two years.
He didn't even
send you an email.
And I hold up my
phone and I say,
we didn't have these back then.
And they think, she
looks amazing for being
200 years old.
I mean, they don't--
it's-- they can't comprehend it.
That's like trying to explain
to someone that there's
no oxygen in the air.
They can't comprehend that.
That's why to me, all
these things aren't
necessarily real to them.
They're clicking and
favoriting and reposting
without really thinking
about what they're doing.
Sorry.
SACHIT EGAN: So if I may,
that's a great transition
to what I was getting at.
In both Jon's book
and in your book,
you do a great job of talking
about how Chris was just--
you began this talk with how
Chris was a little different,
even at age 6.
Right.
CARINE MCCANDLESS: He
was more aware than most.
SACHIT EGAN: Right.
He cared about authenticity,
he had principles.
And you describe him as
being unique in that way.
In your book you say
even friends would say,
your brother is a
little intense--
not in a bad way,
but he's intense.
So what I wonder is if
you fast forward to today,
it is still the norm for people
to click on catch me outside,
how about that
instead of the book--
CARINE MCCANDLESS:
How about that?
SACHIT EGAN: Thank you.
CARINE MCCANDLESS:
Let's be fair.
SACHIT EGAN: Fair enough.
It's still the norm
for people to be
attracted to that and not
to stand up in the way
that Chris did.
So what I wonder is do you
have thoughts for students
that you speak to around the--
like, how and why can
be more authentic?
CARINE MCCANDLESS: I mean, some
of it's entertainment, right?
You have students who are going
through these calculus classes
and do they necessarily
want to think that much?
And so part of
it's entertainment.
But there has to be
some responsibility
then and accountability.
Because you can't tell
me that seeing that
and that being so saturated--
and not just that, it's
being rewarded by adults.
It's not other kids that gave
her a reality show, right?
So kids see that.
That's what I'm talking about
is that kind of responsibility
and accountability.
I probably didn't
answer your question.
SACHIT EGAN: No, no, no.
There's no easy
answer to how do you
solve this truth of society.
But I think one thing you
talk a lot about is parenting
and how Chris and you both--
it's beautiful in your
book, you describe
the lessons you
learned about how
you want to do
things differently
than your parents
did, for example.
CARINE MCCANDLESS: Yeah.
And my parents weren't all bad.
I mean, they weren't.
And I talk about that and
I flush it out in my book.
They taught us some
hard work ethics
and a lot of good things, too.
But you have to decide what
you're going to emulate
and what you're not.
And specifically on the
issue of domestic violence,
breaking that cycle is
a very important thing
and it's not easy to do.
SACHIT EGAN: And so
in that same vein,
you talk about some examples
with your own daughters
of how you try to embody
authenticity, positive thoughts
around relationships and around
the relationship with the self.
I know a lot of parents
are either in this room
or watching on livestream.
Do have any thoughts
or tips around how
to embody these values
in your own family?
CARINE MCCANDLESS: Sure.
And I'm not standing up here
like, hey, I'm doing it right
and everyone has
got to get on board.
No, no, no, no.
My 18-year-old, I love her.
She is such a good kid.
I have an 18-year-old
daughter that's never
rolled her eyes at me in my
presence or slammed a door,
right?
Miracle.
Is it because I'm such
an amazing parent?
I'd like to think so.
She's probably not
going to say that.
But let's take that for example.
I take my kids to my events
and sometimes things sink
in and sometimes they don't.
My oldest, she came up
from the basement one night
and I was sitting working
at the kitchen table.
And she came up and I
might get off tangent
and you can reel me back in.
But she came up from watching
a TV show just blubbering.
I mean, she was crying so
hard that she couldn't speak.
And
I'm like oh my God,
Heather, what's the matter?
What happened?
What's wrong?
I can't-- I can't--
I don't remember
the name, Glenn--
[SOBBING SOUNDS]
She just-- I'm like, oh, she's
watching "The Walking Dead."
I've never watched that show.
I don't-- maybe I shouldn't
be letting my kids watch that
show.
I don't know.
But she is beyond herself
with grief, genuinely.
She's a smart kid.
And I say, Honey first
of all, he didn't die.
I hear you talk about
this guy all the time.
I know people that
write scripts,
this guy didn't die, OK?
This is the last show
of the season, trust me.
He didn't die.
They just want you to think so.
But she could not connect--
she's smart, but they're so
disconnected from reality.
It affected her so much.
And it's easier to connect
to things like that.
Now, when I talked to her
about real things that
are happening in the world
and these terrible tragedies,
she doesn't have
the same reaction.
I mean, maybe part of it
is a defense mechanism.
It's not that she isn't
concerned about those things,
but it's--
that is-- that's not
good that that happened.
But it's not this--
and so it bewilders
me sometimes.
But when it comes
to parents, right, I
say maybe I shouldn't
let her watch that show.
Now, I think it's OK for
her to watch that show.
It's probably something I
should have watched so I
could make that determination.
But I talk with other
parents about these issues
and I'll mention how I found
Heather posting something
inappropriate and so I took
her phone away for six months.
And I get this, you took
your daughter's phone?
I could never do that.
Oh my God, she would hate me.
My kid would hate me.
I'm like, well, your kid's 12.
I mean, and I'm not
judging other parents.
Everyone has their
own things going on.
But it goes back to
this accountability
and responsibility.
I mean, you have
to be willing to--
my advice to parents,
you have to be
willing to not be
their best friend
because you have to
be their parent first.
And later in life,
hopefully they'll
realize that you were
their best friend
and really looking out for them.
But we all survived without
phones and computers
when we were that age.
And so you have to--
and my advice to the
students, every time I'm
talking with students, I
always hold up my journal
and I ask them, how
many of people--
how many people in
this room journal?
OK.
I always say, everybody
should journal,
even if it's one or
two sentences a night.
And I don't do it every night.
Sometimes I'm too exhausted.
But the good thing
about journaling,
I always say you do it with
a real paper and a pen.
Why do you think it's
with a real paper and pen?
They want to go
to their devices.
But if you go to
your device, you're
going to be bombarded by
all this stuff-- some good,
a lot bad.
And that's the noise,
this noise of society.
What are your thoughts?
What are you thinking?
Get away from all the
influence and figure out
what your place is in this
world, what you want to do.
SACHIT EGAN: For sure.
You talk about your brother
being your protector all
the time and you see
it in the pictures,
you see it in stories,
you share it in the book.
And I wondered if
his inclination
to think about these deep
things at a younger age
was in part because he
was a protector for you.
He was, in a way, I think
trying to self parent a bit
and provide some positive
influence in your life
and help you, as well.
And so he was taking that
responsibility at a young age,
younger than most
people are comfortable.
And now you're encouraging
kids to journal
and do what Chris did in
taking some accountability
and responsibility
for their own selves.
But you also talk
about parents and I
think what I hear you
saying is, parents,
it might suck if your
daughter hates you for a day,
but that's your kid.
CARINE MCCANDLESS:
Well, she might
hate you loner than a day.
But however long it takes.
SACHIT EGAN: Right.
But I hear you
saying to parents,
take some responsibility to
have that difficult conversation
instead of just batting your
eye or looking another way.
We all need to be
more responsible,
is that what you're saying?
CARINE MCCANDLESS: Right.
And I'm not stellar
at all of this myself.
We, I put we in
this including me.
It's tough for parents of--
I'm 45 years old and I updated
some apps the other day.
I have no clue how the hell
they use these things now,
but my 11-year-old
could pick up my phone
and intuitively
just figure it out.
So a lot of times, when I talk
to parents about social media,
they, oh, I don't even
understand how all that works.
Some of them have the
attitude of you know what?
You've just got
to trust your kid.
But they aren't aware of
a lot of the things that
are happening and the things
that those kids are exposed to.
So you have to be
willing to have
the uncomfortable
conversations, you
have to be willing
to take the phone,
you have to be,
unfortunately, willing
to learn how Snapchat works.
You do.
If you're going to give
them the access to it,
you've got to be willing to--
but let me make a
point here about Chris.
You said that I encourage
kids to do it Chris did.
Chris died out in the
middle of the wilderness.
So I encourage-- people tell
me, I get messages to people
all over the world and people
say that your brother changed
my life.
And I see where Chris inspires
people to make positive changes
in their lives.
But when someone tells
me and they come to me
and they're in
tears and they say,
your brother saved my
life, I say to them,
Chris died in 1992.
He couldn't do that for you.
Now, he can be a spark
that lights a fuel in you
to do that for
yourself, but own it.
You did that for yourself.
And so yeah, I want
people to be influenced
by Chris' desire to have
a purpose in life, right?
He died so young, but he's
influenced so many people
without even trying to,
and for the most part
in very positive ways.
But Chris was also accountable.
He knew that he put himself
in a very difficult situation
and he didn't blame
anybody else for it.
I talk a lot about our childhood
and my parents in my book,
but I don't blame
them for his death.
Chris put himself out in
the wilderness unprepared.
I do hold him accountable
for his disappearance,
and that's a very
different thing.
So one of the greatest
lessons that people
can learn from Chris and kids
of that age is to be accountable
and to have that self-awareness.
Because at the end, I don't
know if we have time for it,
but Chris--
I put some more slides up
here simply because there's
a lot of things-- that's
me hiking to the- us,
Chris on the road.
So just very quickly,
at the end of the movie,
they show this note.
So this is the note
that Chris wrote
when he knew he was dying,
I have had a happy life
and thank the Lord.
Goodbye and may God bless all.
So he had taken that page
out of one of his books
and on the opposite
was this excerpt
from a poem by Robinson Jeffers
from "Wise Men in the Bad
Hours."
It reads, "Death's
a fierce meadowlark,
but to die having
made something more
equal to the centuries
than muscle and bone
is mostly to shed weakness.
The mountains are dead stone.
The people admire or
hate their stature,
their insolent quietness.
The mountains are not
softened nor troubled
and a few dead men's thoughts
have the same temper."
Chris didn't do anything
without a purpose.
He didn't just randomly
pull this one page
and decide to write the
last words that he's
going to write in his life.
And he also didn't
do it for us, he
didn't do it for anybody else.
He didn't know that
anybody was ever
going to find this or care.
When the students
take pictures, what's
the first thing we all do
now when we take a picture?
SACHIT EGAN: Uploaded it.
CARINE MCCANDLESS: Maybe you
since you work for Google.
I haven't uploaded
pictures in a long time.
I'm so behind.
No.
The first thing we do is
we look at the picture.
We look at the picture.
Did we get the images that
we're looking for, right?
But Chris, these pictures that
people see online of Chris,
Chris never saw these pictures.
That was back in the day where
you had this thing called film
on a roll and you had to
take it to the drugstore
and get it developed and
you don't even know what
the images--
but Chris, there aren't five
of these pictures, there's one.
He didn't take it,
let me make sure I'm
getting the right shot.
And Jon writes
about, which is not
a picture I have up here because
it's too difficult for me,
and I read it at the
end of my Ted Talk,
I believe, but he writes
about this photo of Chris,
the last photo that
Chris takes of himself,
and he talks about
how he's standing
beneath the
highlights of the sky
and if he feels betrayed that
his body has let him down.
I'm totally-- Jon wrote it
so beautifully and I just--
I have it here.
Let me just do service to this.
It just takes a minute.
So he talks about this and
he quotes Jeffers' poem
and he says, "One
of his last acts
was to take a picture of
himself standing near the bus
under the high Alaska sky, one
hand holding his final note
toward the camera
lens, the other raised
in a brave beatific farewell.
His face is horribly
emaciated, almost skeletal.
But if he pitied himself in
those last difficult hours
because he was so young,
because he was alone,
because his body
had betrayed him
and his will had
let him down, it's
not apparent from
the photograph.
He is smiling in the
picture and there is no
mistaking the look in his eyes.
Chris McCandless was at peace,
serene as a monk gone to God."
That picture that Jon's talking
about, it's not this one,
is both the hardest and
the most wonderful picture
for me to look at.
It's a good pain, I call it,
because I see he's dying,
he's skeletal.
But he does have
this genuine smile.
And there's one shot.
He didn't take a bunch hoping,
oh, am I going to get it right?
Am I going to put the
right thing across?
He's not thinking
about anybody else.
That's just pure emotion
coming out of him and it's real
and it's genuine and it happens
to be because of his faith.
But for any of us, whether we
live a young number of years
or whether we live
into our 80s and 90s,
to have that peace at
the end of our life,
whenever that time comes, to
me that's what it's all about--
to be at peace with
the past you've
chosen in life in the way
you've lived your life, what
the purpose of your life was.
And although Chris'
life was short
and although he
was so devastated
to be losing his life
at such a young age,
and I know this from reading
his journal, he was at peace--
not because he was dying,
but because he had lived
and the way he had lived.
And to me, that's my advice for
students is use those journals,
figure out who you are,
figure out what you want to be
and what you want to do.
And when that day
comes for you, and it's
going to come for all
of us unless you guys at
Google here figure out--
I mean, it might be coming,
I'm sure you're working on it--
better find us to
some other planets
because it's getting
a little crowded.
SACHIT EGAN: Talk
to Elan about that.
CARINE MCCANDLESS: Yeah.
We'll talk to Elan about it.
But that's my point.
SACHIT EGAN: Do you see any of
Chris' traits in your children?
CARINE MCCANDLESS: Well, yes.
So Heather isn't
biologically my child.
I adopted her.
So as far as traits if you
mean that have traveled down
biologically.
Christiana, my youngest,
she is named after Chris.
She has Down syndrome.
Doesn't matter.
Nothing is going
to stop this kid.
Things that remind
me of Chris in her
are why can't I go
climb a 100-foot oak
tree to play with the raccoons?
I don't understand
why that's a problem.
I mean, but there's also
just this purity in her.
Obviously, she doesn't have--
I don't know, she's only
11, I guess we'll see.
But I mean, her deep thoughts
right now are about princesses.
But there's a light
and a pureness in her
that I definitely recognize.
Yeah.
SACHIT EGAN: Very cool.
Anybody else?
CARINE MCCANDLESS: Did
I talk so much that I
answered all of your questions?
SACHIT EGAN: That's fair.
I'll ask you a final one then
and we can go to book signing.
CARINE MCCANDLESS:
Are you guys going
straight to a conference room
to figure out this whole issue
after this?
SACHIT EGAN: We've got a book.
CARINE MCCANDLESS: How to
populate good influences coming
into people's pages.
SACHIT EGAN: This is
one you and I have
talked about a little bit.
But when I went and
visited the bus in 2012,
there's some supplies and
things and notes and journals
that people leave behind
for future visitors.
And what was amazing
when I visited was
there was in a plastic bag
one of Carine's journals.
And I think it's the one that
you had taken with you when
you first visited the bus and
you'd left it there for people,
I think, to write in.
And getting to the
bus is not easy.
It's 40 miles round trip.
You have to cross two
rivers, it's the middle--
the mosquitoes are insane.
And I remember
we'd gotten there,
we'd done a 20-mile
day that day to get
to the bus and the
first thing that I
see on the cover of this
journal is a Buddhist quote that
said, "There is no
way to happiness,
happiness is the way."
And it occurred to me that
I'd taken this journey
to find something at this
bus, as it did by the graffiti
there hundreds, maybe
thousands of people,
all seeking something.
But this quote talks
about it being within us.
Can you talk about it
all that has resonated
with you in your life?
CARINE MCCANDLESS: That's
it, self-awareness.
If you don't get away from
that noise of society sometimes
and you don't have
that self-awareness.
I mean, it breaks right down
to kids going to college
or they don't go to college,
they go into a career.
Are they doing that
they want to do,
or are they doing what
they were told to do?
Are they following
their own path
or are they following a path
that was laid out for them?
It's not just academics,
it's also socially.
All of these influences that
are all over the internet
are determining these
paths and these choices
that we all make all the time
and the kids are watching it.
SACHIT EGAN: A round
of applause for Carine.
Thank you for being here.
[APPLAUSE]